Dr. Southwick and I, Steve Southwick, my co-author,
we're psychiatrists and we over many years,
over about three decades working together,
we have been trying to understand what causes
serious forms of depression both biologically
and psychologically, serious forms of post
traumatic stress disorder and other anxiety
disorders, developing new treatments.
And then at one point about 15 years ago we
decided to study resilience and that is individuals
who, despite having been seriously traumatized
in their life, whether it was combat or rape
or physical abuse or facing a serious illness,
they were able to rise above it.
They were able to bounce back, in other words,
be resilient.
We thought if we could understand resilience
we could help our patients discover new treatments
and help people in general because everybody
at some point in their life faces tough challenges.
So we started 15 years ago to identify people
that we thought are resilient.
We interviewed 30 or more prisoners of war
from Vietnam, and the reason for that is that
we had found out that the POWs from Vietnam
who had been held for six to eight years in
prison, heavily tortured in solitary confinement
for years, many of them had done well when
they got out.
The most famous example is John McCain.
And through that process over many years,
we started hearing the same thing over and
over again about what enabled people to get
through tough times and that ultimately led
to this book that discusses ten ways, ten
factors that relate to resilience, and we
also became convinced that you can essentially
train yourself to be a more resilient person
and we hope the book enables you to come up
with some ideas to do that.
One of the ten factors is optimism, having
a positive attitude.
We found, and research in general has found,
that optimism in part is genetic.
I'm sure many of you know people that just
seem to see the glass half full.
They have the confidence that they think they
can get through tough times.
They're optimistic.
So genetics is part of it, but genes are not
destiny, and in some cases you can help people
become more optimistic.
In fact, there is a form of therapy for depression
and anxiety problems called Cognitive Behavioral
Therapy and that can enable you to become
a more positive person.
Now, but the kind of optimism that is important
is not Pollyanna optimism, optimism that doesn't
fully take into account the challenge that
you face.
There is a term called the Stockdale Paradox.
Jim Stockdale was a heroic POW, and the Stockdale
Paradox really defines the optimism that is
most important in becoming a resilient person
and that is, when you're faced with a challenge
or a trauma, you look at that challenge objectively.
You might make the assessment, “I'm in really
big trouble.”
You have a realistic assessment of what you're
facing.
On the other hand, you have the attitude and
the confidence to say, "But I will prevail.
I'm in a tough spot, but I will prevail."
That is the optimism that relates to resilience.
Having strong social support is a very important
ingredient toward becoming resilient, and
one of the analogies that we use relates to
the POWs that we studied.
The POWs from Vietnam had developed a tap
code that enabled them to communicate through
the wall to an individual, another POW in
the cell next to them.
They weren't allowed to talk, but they developed
a tap code, and the tap code involved tapping
on the wall and it involved five letters in
five rows.
If you tapped once that meant row one and
then three times would be the third letter
in that row, so the first row was A, B, C,
D, E. They tapped once, row one, three times
and it's letter C, and so they developed that
kind of tap code.
They told me that if they didn't have a tap
code to communicate with somebody they couldn't
even see for years they wouldn't have been
able to have gotten through that experience
and stayed sane.
They developed friendships for life through
the tap code from one cell to another.
So our analogy is, everybody needs a tap code.
Everybody needs a set of individuals in their
life that they can count on, that they can
share their feelings with, that they can ask
for advice in terms of facing a trauma.
Social support is very important.
Very few people can go through it alone.
So search with your friends and your family
members to develop a network of friends that
you can really communicate with.